[Applause]
[Music]
transylvania
it's like catalonia with vampires yes
you heard that right the land where
dracula was born is also the place of
one of the most significant
separatist conflicts in all of europe in
other words transylvania well it is the
perfect place to make a visual politic
halloween
special
[Music]
and yes yes yes we do read your comments
we do know that you want a video about
catalonia and i tell you what we are
working on it is going to be big it's
going to be complicated
and it's also going to be worth the wait
i promise just sit tight for catalonia
but for now
let us get back to transylvania which is
a historical region located in the
center of romania
despite being inside romania 20 of its
population
doesn't even speak romanian instead
their mother language happens to be
hungarian indeed in some areas the
number of hungarian-speaking people
rises to 80 percent this area where the
hungarians are the majority is called
the sika land
almost every year you can see the
massive protests of zecalis demanding
more autonomy for their territory these
demonstrations are celebrated in the
main cities of transylvania
as well as bucharest the romanian
capital and budapest the hungarian
capital but hold on for just a minute
because things
are more complicated than they seem in
fact elise don't want to have their own
country
instead they want to become a special
region inside of romania
with a very specific fiscal system so
the question
here is well why does this cause so many
problems for romania
why are these demands creating such a
significant diplomatic conflict
and well more importantly the question
is what does the hungarian government
have to do with this
well do not worry because today well of
course we're going to answer all of
these questions but as usual before we
do all of that
let's go back and take a look at the
history
[Music]
hairy tongues so for centuries
transylvania
was part of the kingdom of hungary back
then romania it wasn't even a country
the upper classes and aristocracies
spoke hungarian
and romanian it was the language spoken
by the peasants
at some point in history romanian
speakers were even prosecuted by the
authorities
we call this process the maguirization
basically these hungarian rulers they
wanted to
impose their culture at any cost to
those
aristocrats romanians were sort of
hillbillies who had a special love for
stealing things
and a bad sense of personal hygiene in
fact there was even a term to refer to
these romanians
they were called zorros nyelvu this
literally means
with a hairy tongue
so during the 19th century the
government closed iranian-speaking
newspapers
and they even forced a lot of citizens
to change their romanian name
to a hungarian one despite this well
after world war one
things they really changed the
austro-hungarian empire lost the war
and one of the things that happens when
you lose a war is you usually lose a
part of your territory one of those
parts well that was transylvania which
was incorporated into romanian suddenly
these peasants that were oppressed by
the hungarian nobility
they had power and with their power well
they wanted revenge
and this is how the first attempts to
destroy the hungarian culture well
that's how they started
and well it certainly wasn't an easy job
do not forget that despite being a part
of romania transylvania was the home of
over one
million hungarian speaking people these
people they were called the sequels and
for
generations they have been speaking the
language of istvan orkney but things
they got a whole lot uglier during world
war ii
hungary well they once again chose the
wrong side to ally with
with the hitler's help they took back
their former territories and struck back
against those who wanted to erase
hungarian culture
in the country as you might imagine this
helped to make the romanians even more
angry
then in 1945 well the germans they lost
the war
that meant of course that their allies
also lost and that included the
hungarians
so romania with a brand new communist
government well they took transylvania
back
this time though they had an even bigger
taste for payback
[Music]
so maybe you remember this other video
where i told you about the dictatorship
of nikolai ceausescu
if you've seen it you already know that
the communist romania well it was the
closest thing to a european north korea
that existed
1 in every 30 romanians was a part of
the political police
and they prosecuted not only those who
opposed the government but
even those who dared to speak hungarian
from
one day to the other ceausescu closed
newspapers
and forced those shekels to speak
romanian even in their own homes
majorization bad as it was forced a few
romanians to change their names
romanization was the same sort of thing
just on a
way bigger scale but hold on for just a
moment because it still doesn't stop
here
on their path to destroy even the last
resemblance of hungarian culture
the romanian communist party forced
thousands of citizens to set up in the
hungarian-speaking territories
this way hungarian speaking became a
small minority in cities like order or
satomare
basically the whole area that borders
with hungary became a romanian majority
region despite all of this there is a
region that did manage to keep their
language and traditions intact it's the
one we mentioned earlier
it's the so-called zika land
romania steals from us so in 1991
romania
passed this brand new democratic
constitution the constitution recognized
the right to speak hungarian but
as you can imagine after decades of hate
against budapest
those seekers they were far from happy
think about it i mean fiscally romania
it's a very centralized country
almost all the taxes are collected by
the central government
and then they share that money among the
regions with a focus on the poorest ones
this puts transylvania in a pretty bad
position
and that's because well they are one of
the wealthiest regions
and so well this is how a new political
party was born
and that would be the democratic
alliance of hungarians of romania also
known as udmr
unsurprisingly they want all the
elections in the regions where
hungarians are the majority
so well what are their foundations well
basically they claim that romania is
essentially sucking their lifeblood
their money yeah it's pretty much the
same situation as in catalonia and their
solution to
end this romanian looting is imitating
the fiscal model of another spanish
region and that would be the basque
country
unlike other regions the bas citizens
don't pay their taxes to madrid but to
their local government instead
[Music]
once the money is collected the local
government has to give some share to the
central government
but the rest is to be managed the way
the local government wants so this was
the system that was proposed by the
seekers in 2014
and guess what the romanian government
replied well they said it was against
the constitution the romanian
constitution starts off by saying that
it is a sovereign
unitary and indivisible country now of
course this
is something that created a whole lot of
protests in a whole lot of different
cities
there were referendum attempts and all
sorts of other symbolic objections
and these are all things that really
hurt the romanian ruling class
[Music]
romania's ruling party threatens
autonomy seeking transylvanian
hungarians with princess and punishment
attempts that threaten the
constitutional order of romania should
be punished with prison if you've been
following the case of the catalonian
separatists well this might sound pretty
familiar
to you but hold on just a second because
well the best
it's yet to come
autonomy or annexation if any of you
have ever been to hungary i'm sure you
might have seen
someone wearing this t-shirt with this
map it represents the shape of hungary
before
losing a part of their territories
before world war one
yeah even today in the 21st century a
lot of hungarians keep dreaming about
taking their old
empire back and among them you'll find
the president victor orban the vladimir
putin of the danube
just like the russian president alban is
famous for prosecuting journalists who
dare to criticize him
he has passed anti-gay laws and he wins
elections with 60 percent of the vote
and of course like every good putinist
auburn likes to rule not only his own
country but others
too orban supports the autonomy of the
zekelys
all right all right i know what you're
thinking why does a president from
another country mess with the
internal politics of another i mean at
the end of the day what the seekers want
is just to have more autonomy
but without leaving romania right well
in fact those seeker citizens
are also his citizens
[Music]
huckery grants citizenship rights to
ethnic hungarians abroad
yeah you heard that right all of those
transylvanian-born hungarians they have
two passports they're the right to study
in hungary
and of course they get to vote in
hungarian elections this last thing well
it's pretty good for auburn i mean he's
popular inside of hungarian borders
but outside he absolutely steals the
show
95 of hungarians from abroad voted for
his party at the latest legislative
elections
meanwhile romania considers these rights
for the seekers as a complete violation
of their own
sovereignty
in their opinion if you vote in two
different countries you can't be loyal
to the one where you
live all this means that diplomatic
relations between hungary
and romania are pretty darn complicated
thanks to this
organ can use romania as an antagonist
to his nationalist propaganda
and then romania will get a great chance
to give some to hungary when it
comes to european politics
[Music]
so now this probably leads you on to the
question of well what's the european
union think about all of this
the truth is despite the council of
europe writing memorandums would they
defend the rights of ethnic minorities
brussels would never let hungary win at
the end of the day viktor orban is like
the dracula
frankenstein and freddy krueger of
european politics so as long as things
don't turn ugly don't expect
any position from any eu institution or
politician
but this is what we think here of
visualpolitik and now we'd love to know
what you think do you think transylvania
should have its own autonomy or perhaps
this is nothing but an attempt by
hungary to get some sway back on their
former territories
well leave your answers in the comment
section below we would love to hear from
you meanwhile if you want to know more
about the old iranian communist system
and the current iranian corrupt system
do not forget to click on the video that
appears at the end of this one and do
visit our friends at the reconsider
media.com podcast they provided the
vocals in this video that are not mine
and do not forget that we publish brand
new videos every monday and every
thursday so hit that subscribe button
and you will not miss any post and if
you like this video please do give us a
thumbs up
and while i wish you a terrific
halloween and if you want to learn more
about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media
we have a podcast at reconsider
media.com
podcast see you there
[Music]
magnetized